congrats on the season
uh we cannot we cannot talk about
anything beyond the first three episodes
so um let's jump in on that um i have a
few questions that actually
sort of don't pertain these are bigger
questions that will not
so hopefully you won't mind uh answering
no no
i'm very curious and i might have to
edit out what i've already just said
um so have you guys figured out or have
you
thought about um if homelander has any
weaknesses
uh we have that's been an ongoing
discussion
in the writers room um
at the moment there aren't many physical
ones but there's so many
psychological ones that that's what we
kind of lean to
that um you know anthony has said many
times
and i agree that a homelander is the
weakest character in the show
uh so we've never really gotten
into the how do you stop him
physically uh but there are a lot of
ways
to stop him psychologically have you
thought about if he ate something that
was bad will he get food poisoning
do you know like uh
i don't think he will i mean someone
just came up with a pitch the other day
in the room of
um is it even possible for him to get
drunk
and i was like i don't think so actually
i bet it can't
be possible um he's just you know
he's physically perfect uh
so there isn't much uh but again i think
but he's he finds his
human vulnerability so
[Music]
hateful and he hates that part of him
and he tries to
subsume it and and yet it
is part of who he is and so um
he hates a part of him that he can't
ultimately control
and so that kind of leads to a stakes a
snake's nest of
psychosis so um you know that
at the moment that is his current
weakness got it you guys like have a
show bible that sort of tells
all the characters you've introduced and
weaknesses
powers like is there one of those kind
of things that you've analyzed
that kind of stuff or is it sort of like
only when it comes up in the writing
process
no we have uh you know our writer's
assistant logan
who's a really smart and good writer
on his own he keeps track of everything
um at any given moment so uh
it just writers rooms are just for those
who don't know writer's rooms are just
conversations you just sit around
and chat about what you think would be
cool in the story and doesn't hit the
themes you want and it's mostly my job
to be the talk show host
you know what do you think that's
interesting tell me your response
and and so when details come up
uh we say oh wait i forget like what is
the deep's
you know this uh hey logan what is it
and he'll have it
almost on immediate recall so it's not
like we have this big
bible in front of us it's much more
informal but we we do all have the
information
at the ready if we need it uh have you
guys figured out how many people on the
planet
uh actually have super powers
uh it's very small um
we spoke about it early because even in
the
pilot they i think they put a number on
it
i think it was like there were 300
active heroes which tells me that
you know there's maybe a couple thousand
tops
worldwide i mean you know it might be
like a thousand i think i think bot
has been pretty selective about who they
give v to and i think
uh uh homelander was only able to get so
many doses around the globe so
i actually think it's a very small
number it does seem like with the
beginning of season two in the first
three episodes
and and from the last season to this
season that um there are some adults
that are being injected with uh compound
v
um is it one of these things where
anyone who gets the injection
it works on them um
no it's a it part of the journey of this
season
is i don't think it's spoiling anything
to say it's like vaught is
hoping to get uh a more stabilized
compound v um you know homelander says
it at the end of last year
which is like you know there's a reason
they don't give it to adults very often
and this year you'll even see kind of
coming up in
an upcoming episode that's not in the
first three you'll see
firsthand what the effects are when you
know you're giving a lot of v to people
and you know i think sometimes it works
i think sometimes
they become freaks sometimes they
explode it's
it's it's quite a game of russian
roulette it's quite messy
um children tolerate it the best the
younger you are
the easier it is and so i think vaught
is looking for a way that they can
inject adults because that would be
uh more profitable for them sure um
on the train in the first three episodes
when huey meets uh annie
uh uh there's a poster in the background
for the church of look at the collective
yeah um obviously you guys are poking
fun or at least talking about
scientology
um is there a what is that like in the
writer's room in terms of our
can we poke fun at them how dangerous is
this and what's amazon's sort of
relationship on this you know in terms
of
be careful i mean you know
no comment on whether it's scientology
or not
i will let viewers draw their own
conclusions
um you know look
yes or some people were you know
especially like
uh like craig rosenberger he's like you
know are people gonna be
you know lurking outside my office now
and um look my overall feeling is
uh it's bigger than any one
thing is really the truth like i have no
problem
with religion uh you know in
in season one my problem was
uh using religion as a prophet center
um i'd say my problem with a lot of
you know these kind of fad religions
um are sooner or later the punch line is
and and we need that check
and for me that is kind of counter to
what the point of these things
are you know uh uh they're
ultimately a way to make money
i find that really distasteful so i tend
to
take target at that uh whenever i can
i don't blame you i understand and i
agree
um so uh and also with the boys though
you poke fun at everything
it's not like there's just one i mean
you are satiring and making fun of and
you know i mean you know i i would say
we're making fun of the right wing
the left wing all the wings uh
celebrities politicians we we tend to be
an
equal opportunity offender 100 um but
speaking about that poster that you see
in the background that brings up the
subject of sort of like easter eggs
yeah are there things um in season two
specifically in the first three episodes
that maybe fans want to like look out
for that they might have
missed watching it the first time oh for
sure
um we layer in a lot of that stuff
um i would pay just off the top of my
head
like i would pay careful attention to a
lot of
the art and posters that huey is walking
past when he's in the um
uh when he's in the pawn shop uh
we sort of intentionally layered in
many things from without giving too much
away there's a
character who will show up in season
three who we
layered in there specifically there's a
a superhero named liberty who will be an
important character a few episodes down
she's advertising her special own brand
of douche
uh pot claws poster is there from
terminal beauty three
you know so we we layer in because it's
a show that allows
us to have media everywhere um
we usually our gray wall our production
designer is pretty great about being
specific about layering and that that
media helps
you know tell the story of where the
episodes are going
got it um how tough was it to get chris
hansen
it wasn't that tough i mean no
disrespect to chris hanson
he uh i think he he thought it was just
like a funny idea
and jumped in and um and i was so happy
to have him i
like for me for me like to catch a
predator
it was such a seminal piece of
uh like news magazine
media for a lot of people my age and
growing up so to be able to have him
with that
voice it was just was just awesome vaude
originates
in nazi germany it's a big um
development in season two
um when did you guys think was that
early on you guys knew this arc of where
was going and
have you sort of figured out where
ultimately the whole
you know where it's all going uh
we'll answer the first question um
that vaught was using
um nazi technology
was one of the very first things
i wanted to do one it's
a certain amount of it is from the books
from
you know the the character their version
of jonah vogelbaum was
was like uh um was like a
a a german scientist who then
defected over here and
lost his family in the concentration
camps um
the you know my version which was you
know a lot of the operation paper clip
scientists
um my version was a version of that
except
it was bought and that he was a full-on
nazi and doing the experiments in the
concentration camps
in my very very first pitch to anybody i
pitched that detail
because i thought that was such a grimy
notion
of of how compound v was originally
developed it was just
it was rotten from the start you know
and it was
and it was just tested on concentration
camp prisoners
by the dozens and dozens um
you're all this human experimentation i
just i like that it's
that it's beginning was so rotten um
and then in terms of where it all goes
yeah i mean as much as i know about
anything uh you know they're always
cocktail napkin sketches you know what
what we really know is
we understand like the escalation
of the forces and how they're heading
towards kind of an ultimate
showdown um like we know a lot about
that
and certain things have to um
twist and turn within bought to allow
that to happen so
you know i i know some of those but um
but it's you know it's a it's a rough
sketch and it allows for
you know you want to leave enough room
for the writers to surprise you
sure did you know when you guys were
making the series that
amazon wanted to premiere the first
three and then go weekly
or when did that sort of come about
because episode three
ends on like a pretty big thing yeah
no that was by that was by luck uh
that episode three ends on on a pretty
good cliffhanger
um although you know not to not to
douche it up and by myself in the back a
lot of them do like we tend to
we tend to try to end them on
cliffhangers specifically
um to promote you know either binging or
tuning back in the next week
um that's that's part of it's by design
the torture of the audience
the uh the airing schedule
came actually when already we were
pretty close to being
uh done we were you know probably
three-fourths of the way through
post-production
um it for the record it didn't come from
amazon it came from the producers it
came from me and seth and evan and
neil moritz um were the ones who
pitched them and and a lot of people
over there were actually reluctant
uh because it was a new idea or they
don't do it that often and we were kind
of
you know we we really wanted it and and
amazon ended up agreeing that they give
it a try
you know our feeling was that you know
we when it airs all eight at once
it gets it becomes such like a
sugar rush of a binge you know people
burn through it in a week or two and
then
so there's an intense amount of activity
and then it sort of fades and then
everyone's kind of off to the next thing
and sure and we were like you know
there's so many great moments in season
two we want to give it
time to marinate so people can just like
reflect on it and talk about it before
they move on to the next
thing and and maybe just be in the
conversation a little bit
longer and also have like
you know i think a little anticipation
for the fans is healthy i think it helps
the experience you know uh there's a
reason they call it
binging like in the real world that's
not great like in the real world
you should have like a couple you know
good meals and then have some time in
between those meals to digest those
meals
uh so we're we're hoping
well it'll be interesting to see what
happens well i'm as a fan
i actually do like the idea of it being
weekly but as a
someone who runs a website i love this
because you're 100 right if it comes out
on a friday
by tuesday most people have injected it
and are on to the next thing
and if you do it weekly the way you're
doing it each week fans are talking
about what could happen next
and it's you know people are it's i
think
for something like this it's going to
totally work yeah and i think
it's just more fun it's more i mean it's
fun to be in the fan experience
and if you can speculate and guess and
connect
you know i mean my other show
supernatural
would probably have been an entirely
different fandom had it
just been binging you know it's about
that connection of discussion
over a period of time that that makes
the experience more rewarding
how much you guys pulling from the
comics and how much are you sort of
making it your own
what's that balance of you know what i
mean
yeah um you know
the things i try to get from the comics
are
i try to get the characters right um
i try to get the tone right
or at least my interpretation of the
tone
uh because those are a lot of the things
that i fell in love with in the first
place
and then you know we try to get um
whenever we can
we try to get like you know story points
or references or characters or easter
eggs or
lines of dialogue even whenever we can
um
they're very different pieces they're
they you know we're a streaming
show so we have to be serialized the
comics are quite episodic
um so it's it's it it proved to be very
difficult
to do a one-to-one in terms of
just playing those stories um and also a
lot of those stories just don't wouldn't
translate just because they're different
mediums um
so you know in in terms of the plot the
plot i would say
is the big thing that's quite different
very different um
but i think that ultimately was a
necessity but um
within that plot we're trying to plug in
as much from the original books as we
can
uh you have a great small bit with seth
rogen uh talking about the translucent
franchise
are you alluding to the fact that uh
seth and evan are running the
translucent franchise in the movies in
this world
no no no seth is the uh he's like the
agent coulson
of the of the vcu is what we've talked
about because
in season one he he's he shows up
in a uh promo for the black noir movie
um and so now here he is in season two
talking about his work in the
translucent movie so
he's sort of like the clark greg of the
vcu
he kind of connects all the way through
it um
and uh yeah so that's just like a
random running joke for us when we spoke
a while ago
and this question might be null and void
by the time i air this
um but you mentioned the billy butcher
short film
that will sort of the deleted scenes
from episode two that you
turn into a short film um do you know
where and when it's gonna premiere have
you figured it out yet
uh it's soon after
the season drops i mean i think we're
gonna release one two and three
first and then probably within a week or
so
after that um the
uh it'll be on x-ray so if you click on
if you just hit pause
on any of the episodes you'll see a
button that takes you to the amazon
x-ray
which is sort of like dvd special
features there'll be
you know scene commentaries and
background details on the actors
and but then also this this short film
did you say how long it is uh
it's about oh man seven minutes
i'm completely guessing but it's in the
seventh it's like a seven minute
it's between three and minutes in an
hour yeah i don't know
i don't know it's it's a it's a measure
of time in real life
i'll say that got it um uh
when you guys were designing season two
and the way it started
um did it almost go in a different
direction was it how did you discover
how you wanted the season to go
um and also the revealing pulling back
the curtain on void
like uh you know uh on
when that was going to be revealed it
went pretty much how we wanted it to i
mean
um the first
two months i mean it's really a long
time on this show um
the first two months of getting the
writer's room back together
we're only talking about like the
mythology of the season
um you know we spend a lot of time
talking about what we think like the big
story is
what gets revealed when you know so we
started with like okay who
let's talk about stormfront and what's
her story going to be
and let's talk about you know now that
we know that stan edgar is sort of
taking the place of uh stillwell
giancarlo is taking the place of
lisa shu to kind of be the face of the
corporation
so how do they change what you know does
butcher find his wife
does he not you know like all those
questions right
so we have notions you know like i said
i'm like i kind of want to end up here
but we talk for months about
what is that story gonna look like
um then once we and what happened how
does every character arc
you know which is 12 characters it's a
lot to talk through
uh then we start to look at uh
okay what how do we break that up
into chunks and then adjust it so that
each one feels like its own story
you know because i i hate that i hate
that like eight hour movie [ __ ]
um like go see a move go see a [ __ ]
movie like i'm in the tv business
and my job is to deliver you episodes
and episodes are supposed to be
entertaining units of entertainment and
then when you put them all together like
a transformer
build into something else that's the
goal uh
and people who don't do that uh are not
actually doing the job of making
television
yeah sorry but i just feel that way so
so we take that big story and then we
figure out
okay how do we make small stories
smaller stories that
move that ball forward on all these
different fronts which is hard it's
a lot of counter balancing but so but
once you know what that big story is
then then the challenge isn't so much
does it
you know does it go where you want it to
go the challenge is just like making
sure you just execute properly
uh the season opens with the rolling
stones uh how
tough was it to get that song it wasn't
you know it was um we looked for a
really long time we had a lot of songs
in there uh i'm trying to remember some
of them but there were a lot of classic
rock songs
there and none of them worked it was
frustrating i think
fleetwood max tusk at one point i
remember that one was a contender for a
minute
uh you know and we were going down the
road on a bunch of stuff
um and then it was our music supervisors
uh thank god who were like hey give uh
give this a try because i think you know
it's not gonna be cheap but i think we
can uh
i think we can probably swing this with
the stones and we dropped it in and
we're like oh thank god that's the song
oh my god that's so amazing why didn't
we think of that before
uh so it was from none of the
like editors or me or phil segretia it
was it was the music supervisors
big win uh you have an alt version of
spotify in your universe
um uh talk a little bit about how that
came about and
do you you know are there other alt
versions if you will
of other corporations or companies oh my
god yes
uh so what makes vot
funny to us or what's been a really
useful running joke
is that um vaught has products
everywhere and everything um
funny enough it sprung from necessity
because
we originally started by wanting all of
these real products
we wanted homelander to
promote you know pepsi or or budweiser
like we wanted them to be doing real
product
um once in a while you'll see a version
of that like we'll have uh
a train we got red bull like they were
the only ones who ever said yes
and and so we they just no one would say
yes because the
the superheroes were such perverts and
so we couldn't and
we're like well how do we create all
these commercials and then we stumbled
on well they're vaught products like we
have to make
it's bought brand beer it's vaught brand
vegetables it's
it's you know uh uh they're listening to
vodify
uh so everything started to become
bought products and then it just became
really funny so like we talked sometimes
they're in the air sometimes they make
it to air and sometimes
we just haven't gotten to them yet like
we think that there's like
a a goop style line called
called vitality um you know
we think there's vnn you know the
channels vnn
and v-e-t and and uh
vaught plus is uh i did notice i think
you had
tmz
we mentioned them you're allowed to
mention them in dialogue but you're
never allowed to show them
so when we show it it's it's some bought
version of it
um but uh uh yeah one of my favorites is
is their new streaming channel vaught
plus that they're they're launching
to great fanfare this year but do they
is it
vaude instead of amazon or does amazon
no no we'll come up we'll come up with
something
there's a uh there's bought restaurants
there's
uh just today one of my writers pitched
whataburger um you know so
it just keeps it vaught just keeps
expanding mod just keeps expanding
um let's talk about uh deep's uh
mushroom journey
sure yeah um you got patin oswald to do
the
voice talk about why patton
you know i i took a certain perverse
pleasure
um that the guy who was like
the lead voice in rat tattooey
um
[Laughter]
comes in to voice the deep's mangina
you know like the guy from secret life
of pets too like a real
real evergreen superstar when it comes
to animated voices and for him to be
like this kind of
animated male vagina on this guy's chest
i just was really hilarious to me man it
just really made me laugh
um it really felt like we were trying to
actively
ruin his career as a as a voiceover
artist
um he reached out to me that was around
when season one premiered and he reached
out to
just on twitter to just say how much he
loved the show and i'm such a big fan of
his
and and um he said uh you know i'd love
to play a part
one way or another if if it ever comes
up and uh that's always a mistake to say
to me because
because i'll always say well it's funny
you should ask that because i
have an amazing part for you and you
could just come into the booth
you know in in the valley and then you
bang it out in a couple hours
and god bless him he was he was willing
to do it and
and was more excited when he
i i said well you'll actually be playing
the deep skills
a lot of actors would say uh i'm
actually busy that year
i can't do it but but he was like oh my
god that's the best i can
i'm so in and
he's a really really good dude talk
about how you filmed
the gills on him because it looks great
um the it's a it was really complicated
um he has prosthetic gills
that are put on him that were that were
you know beautifully
wrought um but those are mostly for
like kind of wide shots or shots that
the gills aren't moving
or um you know if he's running towards
the door
and you catch like a little corner of
one that's mostly what those are for
all the times that they're talking those
are completely cg
element um and uh stefan fleet
our vfx coordinator spent so much time
and and as did i the um
you know because you know they're all
just basically uh uh
scanned onto chase's skin
but one they have to
speak you know we had to record patton
very early so that we could sink the
lips
to him uh and then every conversation
every stupid conversation of like does
one speak at a time do they all speak at
once do the lower ones talk to the upper
ones
like uh how wet are they uh
should they be spitting you know because
they're they're so mucusy
and like these intense conversations
where you're just you're fine-tuning
almost by the pixel
of of spending so much time and effort
and so much love and care on something
so
ridiculously [ __ ] stupid uh
is uh is exactly why i make this show so
one of the things that i love
um and for me is watching you sort of
poke fun at the entire junket situation
and people doing press it might be a
little inside baseball
for people that are watching it that are
like that can't be what it's really like
but that's really what it's like
and you show it in the first few
episodes so sort of talk about
trying to sort of shine a light on what
these press junkets are really like
the insanity that goes on behind the
scenes yeah sure i mean
the show in its own way one of the
elements about it that we love
is it's a very inside baseball show like
we made a decision very early on that we
were really going to get deep in the
weeds
in just details of how show business
works but
never explain it to the audience so
we're always talking about like
ratings points and demos and you know
and and prices per share and
and never giving context for any of it
because that's how it really happens and
we wanted it to feel authentic
um so for this season we said well we
should do a junket because that's a very
inside baseball thing and and
show it you know very realistically
which is what a junk it is is you know
you all
uh gather at one particular location
and like dozens and dozens and dozens
and dozens of press
show up and the idea being is
instead of different interviews on
different days you have like 48 hours of
14-hour interviews a day and you're
running through
you know the interviewer comes in they
ask five minutes of questions they go
someone else comes in they ask five
minutes of questions they go and it goes
on and on
and um and you know through no fault of
their own
but everyone wants to know the exact
same things
and so you're you're asked the exact
same questions
like 300 times in a row
and by the end you're just you don't
even know what you're saying anymore
you're just
you're just speaking whatever that like
first question was
and and just whatever your robotic
response is to that answer
and um and that's really how it goes and
uh so we wanted to just show that uh
you know but we do it for all aspects of
the business like
one thing i'm really proud of is uh it's
an upcoming episode but it's not
spoiling anything
is um you know we show them filming a
movie
and we took great pains to to make that
a very very realistic
movie shoot like even if you're
listening to all the all the um
extras in the background they're all
they're all saying
very realistic uh movie things
um because again it's just it helps with
the authenticity
how often are the seven actually
fighting crime
because one of the things that i've
learned watching the show is that
they're busy filming movies
tv series uh promotional appearances
attending premieres and
never fighting i mean i had a notion in
the beginning it didn't quite
pan out but i had a notion in the
beginning was like i wanted to go
through the whole series and none of
them ever fought crime
once like that was my original goal um
the uh where it kind of landed
is they occasionally
uh are sent by crime analytics
um off on a save that is uh
meant to be uh recorded
and to further polish their
brand um or to get themselves out of a
tight
scrape if they need to change the
subject of some scandal they're in
and but there's always they're never
just out on patrol
uh they're sent by a
group of you know uh
keyboard you know masters who are really
looking
through all the surveillance footage and
imagery
and and they're meant to just go to a
place stand in a place
stop a villain have someone film it and
then they get to be on the six o'clock
news so almost never
i would say almost never almost never
got it
um the you revealed the compound v uh
you know the the it comes out uh very in
the first three episodes
for a lot of series that could have been
a season finale moment
where the compound v you know it's the
last episode and it comes out and
boom what's the next season gonna be but
it's right in episode three
was there ever any talk about pushing
that to being a
season finale moment certainly not
seriously among the writers um
the uh you know the compound v thing
it's a pretty good card trick um which
you always look for
when you're in when you're writing a
season because
it's something that really feels like a
big deal
you know to the audience but it's
actually not a big deal at all because
every main character already knew about
it
um or 80 of them like maybe noir
and maeve didn't know but like
every other character knew and so
it didn't actually affect the story at
all
uh every the boys would keep doing what
they were doing
the seven would keep doing what they
were doing by and large so
it gave you we specifically looked at it
as well let's make it feel
really huge and let's do it way earlier
than anyone's expecting
um because it'll feel like a really big
deal but it's actually not a big deal at
all it's an illusion
that it's a big deal um because it
doesn't change the story one iota
um the big things are the things that
change the story that's why i save
things for like
you know ryan's alive and becca's alive
like
i save those for ends of season because
that changes everything and i need time
to think about how that's going to
change everything uh
but everyone knowing about vaught was
was a cool way to you know to have a
shocker in the middle of an episode but
it didn't change anything i i understand
um
there is a in episode three there is
that bit where homelander throws his son
off of the roof i think it's episode
three maybe it's two yeah that's right
those three and um so was there a lot of
talk about what homelander was gonna do
to try to turn his powers on
you know what was there ever a thought
of shooting him was there a
thought of you know how did it how did
it end up being that
i uh that was also uh craig rosenberg
who comes up with all of our
most twisted [ __ ] um i don't remember
there ever being another pitch i
i remember always from the beginning
there was this idea that
he pushes his son off a roof um
the only thing that was different was we
talked about you know how like there's
always those moments in superhero
stories where like
someone falls and and you're looking
over and it's empty air and you think
they're dead or
then they suddenly fly up you know we
were
we were joking around that like homeland
or there was a version of it at one
point where homelander was expecting
that moment
where like he like pushed him off and
then there was like a lot of pause
and he was waiting for him to fly up and
then he looks over and he sees the
sprawled like
you know unconscious body on the ground
uh
so i think that inspired us that sort of
classic superhero moment
when every character learns to fly they
always seem to fall
and then we think they're in trouble and
then they fly up magically
uh we were playing with that um but
somewhere in the process we decided that
actually watching the child
fall off the roof and impact with the
ground
would be the crazier shot and so we went
with that
uh my last thing that i wanted to talk
to you about um which is
one of the biggest things in the first
three episodes is the whale sequence
um it's obviously bloody as [ __ ]
it is crazy what you put the actors
through um
how long did it actually take to film
that thing and
because you are dousing everyone with
blood it's not like a little bit
it is it's a lot um
is there ever the actors like are you
serious we're doing this for four days
or five days um well crazy enough
um if i remember correctly
the actual bit with the whale
uh the whale was really hard um
because there was storms
when we were doing all the water stuff
in a couple days we actually couldn't
it wasn't safe to go out in the water
and you would have to scramble and
change our schedule around
last second um so and if i remember
correctly
you know there's a lot of different
parts of that sequence you know the
the the boat racing towards shore
is its own full day with a helicopter
uh our director steve boyam you know
riding shotgun in the helicopter
who's you know fun fact of steve boyamas
he was one of the surfers in apocalypse
now
and he's and he still carries that like
you almost picture where
the valkyries is in his head as he's
jamming he's just a madman
and um and brilliant but so there was
that day
and then if i remember correctly the
exterior whale
uh was only one day um
of just you know uh uh them climbing out
of the whale and then all the
superheroes showing up
to the whale uh the boat going into the
whale
uh then inside the whale
we actually because i felt i think we
could only be on that beach for one day
so then inside the whale we had we had
to break down the whale
you know and then take its innards uh
the middle section had all its innards
and drive that to the stage
and then film the rest of it on the
stage covered
when they were most covered in all of
their wet and goo
so i think it was a three-day deal um
all in
and uh it's it's awful that all that
blood
is it's sticky and it's gross and you're
in it
all day when you're outside it attracts
bees because it's
there's so much sugar in it um so like
imagine smothering yourself with
strawberry jelly
and and then and then sitting in it all
day
and that's a pretty solid version of
what they have to go through
um but i think you know i think they
know what they signed on for
and that's all that's all i can say 100
but
you also in the inside of the whale you
have the heart you have the guts
i mean that it's brutal and it looks
awesome
on you know on screen yeah yeah i mean i
think if
uh arv greywall uh the production
designer he wanted it to be anatomically
correct so there was
you know he didn't want to make it a
joke uh so there was a lot of discussion
of like what
cavity in the whale is big enough to
allow all of these characters to play
these scenes and we
we finally landed that well if the boat
goes through and punctures the lungs a
whale's lungs are enormous
and so a collapsed lung
would create just a massive space
um so that that's what we did uh was it
always gonna be a whale
or was it almost something else it's
always gonna be a whale
craig rosenberg was like he really
wanted to top the dolphin
and he was always pitching a whale one
thing was because originally i'll tell
you this
now that i remember uh uh and it's okay
i
have a i have a couple more minutes then
we'll go we'll just be the last question
but um but one thing i remember is
uh uh originally they were going to hide
kenji
in like a safe house in the city
somewhere
and and then uh and then they were going
to escape
because um i think the deep or some of
the superheroes were after them
and they were going to be driving just
like
in new york along the water was at the
west side highway and
and and just driving trying to escape it
was a car thing
and then the the whale was going to come
out of the water and beach itself on the
highway in front of them
and then they were gonna drive through
the whale that was the original
pitch and i kept saying like i don't
understand it like
the highway is so far from the water
like the jump that it would have to make
and the size and like
there's just smarter why not pull down a
bridge like there's just so many smarter
ways to block them
um that i was like not into the whale
pitch
um and then like
i think we came up with the idea that
they're hiding on a boat
because we're like well we need them
somewhere isolated to hide and
i think we came up with the boat because
that would make the whale work
i think the whale i think the whale
wagged the tail of that whole episode
on that note i'm going to say that thank
you for talking to me for six hours
and and no seriously um the first three
episodes are great i can't wait to talk
to you about uh more
and um seriously uh have a great day
i'll talk to you soon
yeah sounds good buddy thank you so much